let's say that we have three small ponds
so this is pond a this is pond B and
this is pond C over here and let's say
that this first pond right over here
it's a privately owned pond it's owned
by it's owned by Al and this pond over
here is owned by Carol is owned by Carol
but this middle pond pond B I guess we
called it to start off with this is
common land or I guess this is a common
pound or this is open to the public open
open to the public open to the public
and let's say that Al and Carol they're
both Fisher I guess Carol would be a
Fisher a fisherwoman they're there they
both like the fish that's how they make
their living and Al and his in his pond
he has fish in there and he does some
fishing in his in his pond but he makes
sure not to over fish because he doesn't
want to deplete the stock of fish yeah
so he fishes just enough that he can he
can pay his bills and whatever else but
not so much that it depletes the fish
and essentially makes them extinct in
his pond so he doesn't want to over fish
and Carol does the same thing
she's got fish in her pond and but and
she uses them to make a living she she
gets them out and sells them and eats
them and whatever else but she's careful
not to over fish because if you over
fished then there wouldn't be fish there
wouldn't be a next generation of fish
but over here in this public pond there
are also fish there are also fish I'll
draw their fish in orange
there are also fish in this public pond
over here they're smiling maybe they
won't be smiling for long and what is
going to happen anyone can go and fish
in this public pond so al might say and
we're just assume we're in a world of
two people obviously the real world has
more than two people I will say okay I'm
going to I'm going to be very careful in
my own pond I'm going to fish just
enough that I don't deplete the fish
there but I can any extra fish I need I
could go over here to this public pond
and fish all I want and I might be
concerned about depletion in the public
pond except for the fact if I'm
concerned about depletion that's still
not going to help
situation because other people might
come and still and still not be so
concerned and so I won't even get the
benefit of the depletion if I hold back
and other people come and deplete the
pond and so when you have this pond that
is open to the public all of the all of
the surrounding people whether it's Al
or Carol or I guess you could have other
people here they would say look I'm
going to fish here I'm going to get some
benefit and even if I over fish my
benefit the benefit of overfishing I'm
going to get on in the near term I'm
going to get all of those fish and then
the cost of that overfishing which is in
the future there won't be as many Fisher
and no fishes and no fish at all that's
going to be spread out amongst everyone
else and so you have the situation where
you have because there's no one I guess
you could say either owning this land or
there's no one protecting this lake or
however you want to describe it you have
there's a a rationale and I want to be
clear rationale does not always mean
good they're rational actors might
decide to over fish decide to over fish
and is essentially by doing that
everyone's going to be worse off they're
going to destroy the productivity of
this pond they're going to destroy the
productivity productivity of the pond of
the pond right over here and this idea
that if there's this common land or
common resource in this case it was a
pond and people can spread out the cost
and they get their benefits directly
you're essentially you have a situation
where that that shared resource can get
abused and this is called the tragedy of
the Commons so this is the tragedy
tragedy of the Commons we're in this in
the example we did here the pond is the
common space that's being that's being
abused and it's a it's especially a
tragedy and I've already hinted at this
already is that even if al decides that
hey you know what I'm going to hold back
a little bit I'm not going to fish so
much because I don't want to deplete it
he'll say but wait if I do that if I do
that other people are going to come and
deplete it so I have no incentive to
hold back and so other people are also
going to have the same logic and then
this thing is going to get over fished
here and the first classic example of
tragedy
where the example was first given was
common grazing land same exact idea if
this was private grazing land over here
where I can keep my cows and my sheep
and this is private grazing land over
here where someone else has their Colin
sheep but this over here is literally a
Commons where anyone can graze their cow
and sheep then just like the fishing
huge incentive for people to let their
cow and sheep maybe over graze the land
destroy the land make it not sustainable
but the costs of it are going to be
shared by everyone else and the benefit
of over grazing at least in the near
term you the the the person who's over
grazing is going to get from it and you
might even say I'm not even the one over
grazing it's all of us collectively over
grazing so you don't blame me now what
is the solution to the tragedy of the
Commons how does a government or
jurisdiction or a group of people avoid
this type of destruction of a resource
well one way that you could do is you
could make this somehow into private
land so if that was owned by the
government it could sell it auction it
off to private people who could then
sell access to this or if the government
does retain control of it it could sell
permits to the land so in this situation
you could sell you could sell permits so
it could figure out hey if someone
fishes responsibly in a given day
they're going to get I don't know $200
or value by doing this so we're going to
make a permit cost I don't know one
hundred and fifty dollars so someone
still has an incentive to do it but that
will also limit the amount of fishing
that can be there and you can have some
you know conservationists that make sure
that the that not too many permits are
given are given for this space over you
and we see that happening if you wanted
to go hunting
there are permits you need to have if
you want to if you want to go fishing in
a lot of places there are permanent to
have if you want to go camping in a lot
of places there are permits because you
could even over a camping area if too
many people are walking there too much
trash is there it could ruin the
campgrounds and so this tragedy the
Commons the best way or the way most
often seen is through this the best way
of preventing the tragedy of Commons is
through some type of a permitting
process